you mean one of the many reasons we all
love you is because you bridge that gap
between big studio films and independent
films don't you we've seen you in both
this year of course I've got a ski
because Prometheus came out this year
and there's word of prometheus - coming
up how do you feel about returning to
work with Ridley Scott and Michael
Fassbender and what would you like to
see happen in the next one if you could
choose anything well I can't wait to
work with those two men again you know
they are amazing fantastic you know I
love working with them and you know who
doesn't want to go to Paradise I would
love to but I think you know it's a lot
of you know questions that you know
Elizabeth Shaw want to ask in kind of
answers do you want to farm find so
there's a lot of things for us to
explore there and I have my own you know
dreams and I own kind of things I want
to kind of go into and look into but
that's something you know that Ridley
and the scriptwriter will come you know
deliver to me and then we would probably
go on another journey and you've got
another movie coming up as well as many
called passion with Brian DePalma me
working on that now you get to share
some scenes this time with Rachel
McAdams you both worked of course on the
last sherlock holmes film have you found
that and how you found working with her
oh we had such a great time we were in
Berlin for three months and I loved
working with her we had such a it was
fun even though we didn't really like
each other from screaming about and he
was there's a really intense journey for
me yeah and then I have dead man Dan
coming out with them Colin Farrell so I
have two movies they were both really
different and quite quite amazing to
work on how'd you get yourself into
those kind of intense roles because we
know you for when you're a fantastic
actress in those terms are you quite
method in that way now yeah I think I
have my own method I I don't really work
the same way ever you know I kind of
always ask myself what do I need to do
for this character do I need to change
my body do I need to you know what you
know what do I do need to do on myself
and then you have to kind of collect
information and do research and then you
just find you know kind of becoming
different personalities and then the
method kind of
comes with it anyway
you